[Music]
our though is more devious than we
imagined
that spire was indeed a teleporter
linked to a cloaked covenant
supercarrier
a grave threat thankfully help is
imminent
60 of the unsc fleet is on route to
reach
from existing deployments the first
battle group should arrive within
48 hours 48
hours that's imminent
uh-oh who's your money on this time
huh you always pick her
she's always had him dialed in that
thing's crushing us and we're waiting
for backup they'll be backing up a
graveyard
all our nukes are either out system or
went down with the ships that carried
them
you're preaching to the converted how
converted i know that look cat
you can say no no you don't even want to
hear it
fine i'll hear it remember that accident
a couple years back
colony ship and route to cygnus 700 dead
vaguely a slip space drive malfunction
right
actually it worked fine the drive was
mounted improperly after a service haul
out when it fired it teleported half the
ship to oblivion
and this is relevant how
a certain covenant super carrier could
with some assistance suffer the same
unfortunate accident even for you cat
that's
inspired not the word i would use
what's going on go ahead
explain may i
don't cut yourself objective
destroy covenant carry on geosynchronous
orbit above us
this sanction sir what do you think
method
a slip space drive in lieu of the nukes
we don't have
delivery system us solvable
getting us up there that and getting our
hands on a slip space drive
thank you for sharing so
all we need is orbit capable transport
and the single most expensive piece of
equipment made by man
as a soldier in the field i couldn't
possibly have access to those kinds of
resources
that said a good place to look might be
i don't know the nearest non-existent
launch site in the non-existent saber
program dismissed by three
administrations as preposterous rumor
and in which our newest member was
certainly never a pilot
it's scary you know that all we need is
a green light from holland
good luck with that you're the one
asking him
[Music]
well there's no way in hell he's gonna
go for this
[Music]
bit of a hike to the launch facility any
closer is too hot to land
could be that commander move up the
beach noble
[Music]
launch facility
hmm
um
roots
uh
look at that
everybody inside four hostels
airborne before he takes a smile you
gotta race on the lower platform
controls right through that door
[Music]
commander
[Music]
so
[Music]
george six get to the saber before the
covenant record
what about you and cat june's on his way
with a falcon
launch team saber is prepped and ready
for launch
[Music]
struts disengaged commencing launch
t-minus
5 1 4 3 2.
[Music]
first stage engine burn nominal
[Music]
stage separation at three two one
stage separation
[Music]
second stage ignition confirmed
[Music]
welcome to operation uppercut i'll be
your control from here on out
understood level six these sabers have
been customized for orbital defense
you may need to get reacquainted
wonderful at anchor nine with frigate
savannah and the other sabers as soon as
you're ready
[Music]
[Music]
we should head for the savannah
multiple unidentified contacts savannah
actual disabled teams be advised we have
bogies inbound
anchor nine to all unsc ships station
defenses are down requesting combat
support until we can bring them back
online here we go show them what you can
[Music]
do
defensive batteries are at 56 hang in
there safer teams
[Music]
oh
much more of this
to unsc ships impulse drive signatures
detected
fighter class heads up savers
saber teams use your guns to take down
their shield then hit them with your
missiles
defensive batteries at 79 buy us another
minute saber team
oh
okay
[Music]
be advised we show a large attack force
inbound combat air patrol and saber
teams are directed to engage and defend
the station
is there any place the covenant isn't
anchor 9 to all unsc ships station
defenses
back online clear the lane
in space
uh
ah
phantom signatures detected on a
forward-facing vector all unsc
fighters multiple inbound phantoms
headed straight for our defensive
batteries
saber teams were marking high value
gunboat targets now
i'm gun votes are in position
damage control teams at the ready man
torpedoes away
bracing for impact
oh
all targets neutralized bravo two niner
you are clear to dock
activating marker holland to bravo oh
two niner
noble five you ready to go
i'm out here six morning spec re-entry
pack disengaged
i need your override warning m-spec
re-entry
cockpit depressurization complete canopy
release lever
[Music]
armed
[Music]
pull up surface grade 19 by 22. gladly
only sword face set to 18g double
enhance
number five your pulse is elevated there
is nothing you can do for dr halsey and
the others inside sword base
the mathematics are determinate noble
five
i know bravo two niner is clear to
re-engage thrusters
level six this is holland go ahead
colonel
we flagged a corvette class vessel on a
predicted docking track with our target
get our makeshift bomb on that corvette
and we have our delivery system
noble five will escort the bomb i need
your saber team to clear the way for
boarding
understood colonel as she's already
donated her slip space drive to the
cause
savannah will be joining you to provide
local fire support
unsc savannah our wings may be clipped
but we've got your back
i've stuck my neck out for noble on this
one lieutenant
we'll get it done colonel six out
[Music]
target corvette cited within visual
range of map beacon ra-15
we have visual target confirmed
[Music]
savannah in position saber team sound
off
echo 1 all systems nominal echo 2 good
to go echo three
systems green echo for all systems
online
solid copy we are currently jamming the
corvette's cons
hitting hard while they can't call for
help agreed
save your teams clear a path to that
corvette
you might want to clip her engines
colonel see if we can slow her down
good thinking savannah that'll make
boarding are a whole lot easier
level 6 and working targets take out the
corvette's main engines
oh
oh
oh
nice
taking fire
so
[Music]
energy flow is detected in the corvettes
after launch days
heads up sabres multiple impulse drive
signatures detected
more bogeys incoming echo tutors have
been actual
where are the reinforcements coming from
i thought the target was jammed
must be squadrons coming back from
patrol echo too
don't let any of them get away savers
kill them before they bug out and warn
that super carrier what we're up to
god analyze all available data on that
corvette find a way inside
scans indicate a structural weakness
surrounding a platform on top of the
vessel
at all six set down immediately on that
corvette's top side landing pad
[Music]
number six the savannah's
countermeasures won't work forever
find a way inside and permanently
disable that cruiser's communications
as soon as we're sure the corvette can't
squawk we'll initiate
uppercut phase two
[Music]
hollinger savannah enemy calm relay is
now offline
copy that halting counter measures
diverting all power and personnel to
weapons
all right noble let's get that slip
space bomb on board
six head for the hangar
on approach
[Music]
oh
go for those shield controls i need in
[Music]
gun copy that six get your fire team to
the bridge
the corvette's refueling run with the
super carrier will have to be initiated
manually
yes sir five stay with the bomb
and discourage the curious my pleasure
hear that lieutenant i'll be all by my
lonesome back here
make it quick
get that corvette moving toward the
super carrier head for the bridge
and find the nav controls got plenty of
arms and ammo if you need
uh
amanda holland sustaining major
structural damage we need to break off
colonel
copy savannah our team is in disengage
damn it i'm losing here
[Music]
savannah actual can you hear me
six nothing we can do
noble you're in deep with no cover get
that corvette moving and
get the hell out of there let's clear it
out
[Music]
[Music]
wow
move lieutenant put that corvette on a
refueling track to the super carrier
well done noble six uppercut initiated
corvette is underway six i ride out of
here is taking heavy fire
get back to the hangar
all clear
at your earliest convenience mobile six
contacts
uh
a pelican
um
um
uh
[Music]
that one
i'm just getting warmed
[Music]
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
me
let's stay down
distance is closing on this vessel's
refueling track with the covenant
supercarrier
76 seconds to at that point so
it's gonna be like that
[Music]
well i've got good news and bad news
this bird took some fire and a thrust to
gimbal is toast which means the only way
off this slag heap is gravity
and the good news that was the good news
at current velocity 53 seconds to end
oh yeah yeah
bad news is time is fried i'm gonna have
to fire it manually
that's a one-way trip we all make it
sooner or later
better get going six they're gonna need
you down there
listen reach has been good to me time
has come to return the favor
don't deny me this
[Music]
tell him to make it count
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you